Have you ever wished there were a magical
way to easily remember foreign language words
and phrases, with little effort?
Nowadays, many language learners claim that
there is such a way, thanks to a flashcard
app called Anki.
Anki claims to "make remembering things easy",
and help you study less, learn more, and do
all that a lot more efficiently than you would
with traditional memorization methods.
Despite Anki's widespread popularity, many
people are shocked when I tell them that I
don't use Anki.
In fact, I don't recommend it at all!
And in this video I am going to tell you why.
Hi, I'm Luca Lampariello.
I'm a language coach who speaks 14 languages.
On this channel, I help people learn foreign
languages faster, more efficiently, and in
a fun way.
In this video, I'll share five reasons why
you shouldn't use Anki to learn foreign language
words.
Before we dive into the reasons why you should
not use ANKI, I want to first give you a little
more information about exactly what Anki is,
and why it claims to be so effective at helping
you memorize words.
The story starts (believe it or not) with
a 19th century German psychologist named Herman
Ebbinghaus.
Ebbinghaus was fascinated by the human memory.
In particular, he wanted to understand how
learning and forgetting play a role in the
memorization process.
So, Ebbinghaus devised an experiment.
He would attempt to learn a set of completely
new information, and then test his ability
to recall learned items over time.
To make sure he couldn't rely on existing
knowledge, Ebbinghaus decided to learn "nonsense
syllables"—three-letter chunks of sound
that had no significance in his native German.
He would make long lists of these syllables—for
example, "wid, zof, taz, bok, and lef", learn
them, and then document his journey towards
reciting each list perfectly from memory.
Crucially, Ebbinghaus tracked a number of
important variables in the process, including
number of repetitions, time between repetitions,
number of syllables, in the list, and so on.
These experiments revealed to Ebbinghaus something
that we now call "the forgetting curve".
The curve is a graph that reveals the rate
at which information is forgotten over time.
Through Ebbinghaus' work, we know that information
that is not reviewed is forgotten quickly,
but information that is reviewed (or "repeated")
shortly before it is forgotten gets a "boost"
in your memory.
This reviewed memory will then be forgotten
at a slower rate than it was before.
If additional reviews are completed, this
rate of forgetting will slow further and further
until we can consider the piece of information
effectively memorized.
The forgetting curve reveals that the timing
of repetitions can be hugely important for
long-term memorization.
It even leaves an enticing mystery: if we
knew exactly when we were about to forget
a piece of information, couldn't we then determine
when to review it, for maximum retention power?
That mystery is exactly why software programs
like Anki exist.
These programs (called Spaced Repetition systems),
use data and algorithms to supposedly pinpoint
the ideal time to review a learned piece of
information.
Following that logic, if you learn with such
software, you would then be memorizing information
in "the most efficient way", because you're
aligning your review sessions with your brain's
natural forgetting curve.
Here's the thing: I have no gripes with Ebbinghaus,
or his forgetting curve.
I'm actually a huge fan of the concept of
Spaced Repetition, and I use it all the time
in my learning.
What I do not do, though, is use Spaced Repetition
software.
I don't use Anki, Memrise, Supermemo, or anything
like it.
I never have.
Actually to be fair, I have given ANKI a shot.
I have toyed with it for a while to make this
exact video.
And now I know I will never use it for my
language learning.
Why?
Well, I've got five reasons why, which are:
Making flashcards wastes learning time
Adding new cards can become an addiction
Reviewing old cards can become a chore
Flashcards take language out of context
Brain-friendly learning strategies make SRS
apps irrelevant
Let's dive right in:
Making Flashcards Wastes Learning Time
One of the hardest parts about learning a
language as an adult is finding the time to
get it all done.
The demands of work and family life often
leave us precious few hours to devote to our
target languages.
For that reason, I strive to spend most of
what language learning time I have actually
absorbing and using the language in a natural
way: by reading authentic texts, listening
to authentic podcasts, watching authentic
films, and having authentic conversations
with natives.
If I were to inject Anki into my language
practice, I'd have to devote a chunk of that
time to inauthentic tasks, most of which boil
down to tedious data entry.
To create a good-quality Anki card, you need
to:
Type in what goes on the front of the card
Type in what goes on the back of the card
Add an image file (if you can find one)
Add an audio file (if you can find one)
Decide what other information you want to
include, like tags, formatting, and different
card formats.
Save the card
That's at least several minutes of work, and
only just for one card!
If you're creating a deck of tens, or hundreds,
or even thousands of cards (as some people
do), that's A LOT of time lost!
Even if Anki does help speed up your memorization
process on the other side, that's a huge amount
of time spent up front just creating and managing
your flashcards.
And that's if everything goes well!
From what I've been told, Anki isn't the simplest
and most functional piece of software, so
you'll probably lose even more time just figuring
out how to get everything working the way
you want!
Not at all worth it, in my opinion.
Save that time, and apply it directly to using
and absorbing your target language.
Adding New Cards Can Become an Addiction
Despite the work that it takes to put together
a good deck of flashcards using Anki, a lot
of that setup is front-loaded.
Once you've planned the structure of the deck,
configured the layout of individual flashcards,
and then added enough cards to get started,
growing the deck actually becomes pretty easy.
Assuming you know where all of your card data
is coming from, adding a new card can take
anywhere from a couple seconds to a minute.
And while the ability to quickly add new cards
might seem like a good thing (and often is),
it's something that can quickly become addicting.
The whole value proposition of Anki is that
it can help you remember anything you want.
Since Anki flashcards are entirely digital,
this actually seems feasible—nowadays, modern
smartphones make it trivial to carry card
decks containing thousands of cards or more,
anywhere you go.
Essentially, Anki removes nearly all costs
associated with adding new flashcards to your
card deck.
Assuming you have the time to make the additions,
there's nothing else preventing you from adding
every phrase you hear in your target language
right to your virtual "memory bank".
There's even software out there that can make
this simple process even easier.
Using programs like subs2srs and voracious,
you can turn an entire movie or television
show into an Anki deck of thousands of cards,
in just a few clicks of a button.
You might wonder what I'm complaining about
here.
Certainly having a fast way to turn movies
and TV shows into learning material is a good
thing, right?
Yes, of course it is!
But if you don't know how to do all this in
moderation, the size of your Anki decks can
quickly spiral out of control.
This is because once you've got a deck of
Anki cards, you need to actually learn them
and review them.
This, incidentally, brings me to my next point:
Reviewing Old Cards Can Become a Chore
If you recall my explanation of the Forgetting
Curve, you'll remember that each time you
learn or review something, there's an ideal
point at which you should review it again.
This helps you strengthen the memory and slow
the speed at which you'll forget it in the
future.
As a software program, Anki's job is to show
you a piece of information (a flashcard),
and then algorithmically determine when that
next ideal review should occur.
So, for example, it might show you a card
for the first time, and test you on its contents.
Based on that result, it could then decide
that you need to review again in a few hours,
or a few days.
When it comes time for you to actually do
that review, Anki will show the card to you
automatically; you don't need to do any extra
work.
This is fine for one card.
But as you go through and learn dozens or
hundreds of cards, these reviews will start
to pile up.
Before you know it, you could be spending
more than an hour each day going through your
Anki reviews—and that's before you even
get to learning new cards for that day.
And if that sounds bad, then you shouldn't
even think about taking a day off.
Because while you're taking your break (because
you're busy, sick, or just unwilling to review
that day), your Anki reviews are still piling
up.
When you come back to Anki (assuming you will,
which is not guaranteed), you'll have a mountain
of reviews to work through.
And that's terrible for motivation.
People first become addicted to adding new
cards, but then become opposed to actually
reviewing them.
This becomes a vicious cycle which ultimately
causes learners to feel overwhelmed and give
up their language learning.
I've seen it time and time again, and it's
not good for anyone.
The tools you use should not only motivate
you to learn, but help you stay on the learning
path for as long as possible.
Anki doesn't seem to do that for the vast
majority of people, which is a major reason
why I don't recommend it.
But I'm not done yet.
Let's move on to the next reason.
Flashcards Take Language Out of Context
My next gripe against Anki is one that I have
against flashcards in general: by definition,
they remove the language you are learning
from its natural context.
Just think about it.
When you picture a flashcard in your head,
what do you see?
A simple card with a word or phrase in your
target language on one side, and the equivalent
expression in your native language on the
back.
For all its bells and whistles, Anki boils
down to just that: a way to take foreign language
content and chop it up into small, isolated
pieces, so that each piece can be absorbed,
reviewed, and tested individually.
Breaking down a lot of information into small
chunks is a great way to learn in general,
but it goes against how language inherently
works.
Language is not just a series of isolated
words and phrases placed neatly next to each
other in a row, like so many beads on a string.
Rather, language functions as a network.
Each word in a phrase, each phrase in a sentence,
and each sentence in a paragraph or utterance
serves to reinforce everything else around
it.
If you remove any one of those things from
its network—the natural context that it
finds itself within—it begins to lose meaning.
In fact, the loss of meaning can become so
great that in many cases, when you remove
a word from its surrounding context, it becomes
essentially meaningless.
You see this practically anytime you look
up a word in a dictionary.
Most words you know have more than one meaning.
But to determine which meaning is actually
being used in a given situation, you have
to look at the surrounding context.
To give a quick example, think of the word
"light".
On its own, light could mean the visible radiation
coming from the sun, or the relative weight
of an object.
But if you put just "light" on one side of
a flashcard, you'd have no idea which of those
two kinds of "light" was intended—at least,
not without more context.
However, if you had never heard the word "light"
before, and I showed you a video about the
sun, you'd quickly learn one meaning of "light",
and automatically connect it to dozens of
words and phrases which can give you context
for that meaning, like "sun", "star", "solar
system", "radiation", "wavelength" and more.
There are ways to mitigate the loss of context
that comes with taking target language content
and putting it on flashcards; however, that
generally requires you to squeeze more information
onto each flashcard, which can then make the
whole flashcard creation more laborious, as
I explored in my first point.
Given the issues that come along with creating
and managing flashcards with Anki, wouldn't
it be great if we could get all of the benefits
of spaced repetition, but without the extra
hassle?
We can!
Which is why, in my next point, I can say
that...
Brain-Friendly Learning Strategies Make SRS
Apps Irrelevant
You might remember that earlier, I mentioned
that I don't use Anki at all.
You may also remember that after introducing
the concept of Spaced Repetition, I mentioned
that I'm a huge fan of the concept, and that
I use it all the time to learn languages.
So what gives?
How is it possible to gain all the benefits
of Spaced Repetition, without also using a
program like Anki (and all the drawbacks that
come with it)?
It's surprisingly not all that difficult.
Thinking back to Ebbinghaus' work on spaced
repetition and the forgetting curve, the main
idea revolves around the benefits of getting
repeated exposure to a piece of information
over a long period of time.
Though software like Anki optimizes exactly
when you do your review, there's not much
benefit lost from just making sure you spread
out your repetitions of a single piece of
learning content over the course of a week,
or even a month.
By reviewing regularly, and giving yourself
time to forget between reviews, you can leverage
the power of spaced repetition, without any
of the maintenance that comes with creating
an Anki deck, and without getting sucked into
the endless cycle of adding cards and declining
to review them.
This is exactly how I structure my Bidirectional
Translation method, which is the method I
follow to learn new languages every year.
I take a short piece of content, learn it
deeply, and then review it in a variety of
ways over the course of a single week.
Then, after that week, I trust that additional
repetitions will just come through learning
and using the language.
Here’s a short breakdown of how it works:
On day 1, I read the content and listen to
the audio, using the translation in my mother
tongue to try to understand the text as deeply
as possible.
On day 2, I analyze the phonetic patterns
of the text—the pronunciation, intonation,
and word stress.
On day 3, I review the content in a brand-new
way—usually through just listening to the
audio, just reading the text, or something
else entirely!
On day 4, I take the target language version
of the text and make a personalized translation
of it, in my native language.
On day 5, I take my native language translation
from the previous day, and try to verbally
translate it back into my target language.
And on day 6, I complete the cycle, by taking
my native-language translation and re-translating
it IN WRITING back into the original language.
Then, I make note of any errors, forgotten
words, or mistranslations.
This cycle of taking a piece of language content
and “processing it” in various ways is
incredibly powerful, and a lot more fun than
sitting in front of my computer, creating
digital flashcards every day!
And it's something you should definitely try,
if you get a chance!
Alright, those are all of the reasons why
I don't use Anki, and why I believe you shouldn't
either!
There are much better ways, which I'll explore
in even more detail in a future video.
For now, let's recap the five reasons.
I believe you shouldn't use Anki to learn
vocabulary in a foreign language because:
Making flashcards wastes learning time
Adding new cards can become an addiction
Reviewing old cards can become a chore
Flashcards take language out of context
Brain-friendly learning strategies make SRS
apps irrelevant
If you want to take a deeper dive into my
Anki-free strategies for Spaced Repetition,
definitely check out the courses in my Become
a Master Language Learner series, both of
which use these strategies to full effect!
I've got a beginner course about my aforementioned
Bidirectional Translation Method, and an intermediate
course about overcoming the Intermediate Plateau!
As usual I left a link in the description
box and in the comment pinned on top in the
comment section.
That's all for now!
Thanks for watching, and I'll see you soon.
Happy language learning!